Hello and welcome to this unusual AI Coffee
Break. Today we’ll give you a teaser about
some of our own work, which was accepted at ACL
2023. We will present it in July in Toronto, so
if you happen to be at ACL in Toronto this
year, do not hesitate to say hi! So here,
we’ll leave you with the bit we
have recorded to present our paper.
Hello! We are happy to present „MM-SHAP” a
reliable way to measure relative contributions
of individual modalities in multimodal models. Why
is measuring multimodal contributions important?
Vision and language models have better and better
performance across all possible VL tasks. But can
we trust they do this for the right reasons?
Fundamentally, these models: are transformers
that work on text and image input. They are
trained, for example, with the image-sentence
alignment objective to say whether a pair of text
and images match or mismatch. Now, there is reason
to believe that not all modalities matter for
these models equally, since they can suffer from
unimodal collapse. This means, even if trained
multimodally, a model can exploit one modality
far more than the other, and indeed we observe
that on multimodal tasks, unimodal baselines can
be close in accuracy to multimodal models. The
reason are often dataset biases: for example,
“how many” questions can be confidently answered
with “two” if “two” is the most frequent answer in
the dataset. Or if questions about existence of an
object can be typically answered with “yes”, due
to so-called plausibility bias. Previous work has
used model performance to assess a model’s focus
on a modality, for example by testing whether it
is sensitive to changing matching image-caption
pairs into mismatching ones, or by measuring
whether their accuracy changes when exchanging
existing images with random ones and questions for
VQA with random questions. Or by deleting image
regions or text tokens and measuring whether model
performance changes. But accuracy-based measures
are not ideal. For example, the visual importance
considers the difference in model accuracy when it
uses both vision and text and with missing visual
information. This is problematic for wrong model
predictions, since in these cases the first term
is 0 and we expect the second term to be zero too
and this results in a visual importance of zero.
But the model may well have relied on the visual
modality, but incorrectly. So, we propose a
performance-agnostic measure of multimodal
contributions. First, we rely on Shapley Values
from game theory. Shapley values compute a
fair pay-out for each player based on their
contribution to a game’s outcome. For example,
if machine learning were a soccer game, we would
first asses the base value, for the game outcome
when no player is playing. Then we gradually let
them play and measure in all possible combinations
of teams from our available players, what the game
outcomes are and we determine how much payment
they deserve. For transformers, the players
are tokens and they receive pay-outs from their
contribution towards the model prediction (for
example the probability or activation value it
computed for a sample) irrespective of whether
its prediction is correct or not. We take the
difference between the model output with a token
being active and with it inactive, and we do this
for all possible combinations of tokens switched
on and off. To get the contributions for a token
(which can be positive or negative), we sum up
and normalize over all marginal contributions. For
vision and language transformers, we have image
tokens and text tokens and we can compute their
contribution towards the model prediction, such as
the image-sentence-alignment score. And luckily,
none of the computations are accuracy-based. We
define MM-SHAP by calculating the contribution
percentage of text tokens and compare it to
the contribution percentage of image tokens,
which can be extended to multiple modalities.
For image-sentence alignment, we hypothesize that
image and text contribute equally on average at
corpus-level because it is useful when comparing
different models on the same task and data. Using
MM-SHAP on sample-level, we see how image and
text tokens contribute towards the predicted 99%
image-sentence alignment score in blue and tokens
that contributed against, in red. Introducing
an error in the caption decreases the alignment
score and the token contributions reflect the
misalignment, with the token “keyboard” showing
negative contribution. At dataset- and task-level
we see that models such as CLIP are multimodally
balanced, while ALBEF models are more textually
focused. This trend holds over VQA data as well.
On the VALSE benchmark, testing models with
fine-grained mismatches, we see even better
that CLIP is balanced, LXMERT has a higher visual
preference, while ALBEF models are more textual,
showing that different VL models behave
differently on the same task. Finetuning
also affects multimodal contributions and with
MM-SHAP, we can measure how much, even in cases
where task accuracy is very low and accuracy-based
metrics would fail. Throughout our analysis,
we consistently plotted both accuracy and MM-SHAP
scores, because we envision MM-SHAP to complement
accuracy, not replace it, since we are of course
interested in how well models solve a task;
but it’s only by using accuracy-agnostic metrics
such as MM-SHAP that we can measure how much
models rely on each modality. We invite
you to read our paper for more details.
Thanks for sticking until the very end of
this, it’s great that someone is interested
in the work I do for my PhD. You know, it’s not
much, but it is honest work. If you liked this,
maybe you want to watch other videos on our
channel. If you like work from large companies
with enormous collaborations, maybe you want
to check out VELO to see how neural networks
can learn to act as optimizers for other networks
– possibly replacing Adam. Or if you would rather
have something by smaller collaborations, maybe
check out this one about A Watermark for Large
Language Models, or the Paella diffusion model. In
any case, we hope to see you next time. Okay, bye!